[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
francia 24 está conmigo ya en el estudio
rosa pérez más euros a bienvenida buena
mañana de viernes y puede ser una mañana
enlutada sobre todo en japón con la
noticia digamos hasta el momento del día
y es el asesinato del ex primer ministro
japonés shinzo abe que fue alcanzado por
disparos o por una persona de 41 años
mientras él estaba pues haciendo acto de
campaña para las elecciones legislativas
a la cámara alta del próximo domingo a
las cuales él se estaba presentando rosa
buenos días raúl y efectivamente no la
noticia del día de momento y esperemos
que no pase nada que supere este nivel
de violencia y como comprenderás y como
comprenderán ustedes esta noticia llena
titulares de la prensa japonesa y de
alrededor del mundo
sin embargo enfatizar en que todavía nos
movemos en un terreno pantanoso respecto
a las motivaciones de este asesinato y
un poco a las circunstancias que se
están todavía investigando sin embargo
raúl si te parece vamos a destacar un
poco los puntos que ponen en común de
momento distintos medios de japón por un
lado bien obviamente es recordada su
figura su legado el primer ministro más
joven en ser elegido y también el más
duradero en el cargo por otro lado
también la desolación tanto de la actual
la primer ministro fue un yo quisiera
como de líderes internacionales
empezamos si te parece por asa y aquí
detrás tenemos y algunos de estos medios
que rápidamente sintetiza lo que sucedió
se oyó el ruido el ruido de un disparo
cerca de la estación kintetsu llama co
en la ciudad de nara y el ex primer
ministro shinzo abe quien estaba dando
un discurso en frente de la estación se
desplomó fue trasladado en ambulancia al
hospital y murió en una conferencia de
prensa en el hospital los médicos
aseguraron que encontraron dos disparos
en el cuello que llegó al hospital con
una paro cardiopulmonar daño en vasos
sanguíneos y en el corazón bien por otro
lado también algo que ha sido muy
destacado es que supuestamente el arma
del crimen sería una arma casera y
precisamente este mismo medio habla con
distintos expertos criminólogos y
precisamente un profesor de la
universidad de nyon experto en
terrorismo señala que es algo sin
precedentes no la muerte bueno el
asesinato de un líder político pues con
una arma casera y que digamos sienta un
presente precisamente muy muy peligroso
por otro lado y ello me euro señala algo
que está creando una cierta confusión no
y es que precisamente el principal
sospechoso en siendo interrogado por la
policía aseguró que no siente rencor
contra en las creencias políticas del ex
primer ministro al tiempo que según las
autoridades este asesinato fue cometido
precisamente por descontento con el
mandato de éste el líder político bueno
todo esto como decíamos no hay que irlo
matizando iremos viendo en las próximas
horas porque por otro lado también
mainichi otro medio que algunos pueden
tachar de sensacionalista hay que
advertir de esto señala que según
fuentes cercanas al periódico este
hombre no intentaba atacar al ex primer
ministro sino a un líder de un grupo
religioso que la policía asegura que no
se encontraba en el lugar de los hechos
también está esclareciendo el estado
mental del atacante por ver si se podría
responsabilizar criminalmente de sus
actos por otro lado ni que dice el
atacante podría ser un ex marine como
nos adelantaba nuestra corresponsal por
otro lado sanz que y también como otros
medios japoneses como decíamos no entre
las reacciones internacionales que
comentábamos pues la del kremlin la de
putin era un verdadero patriota
lamentando este asesinato y también
acaban señalando que la policía habría
encontrado ya artefactos explosivos en
el domicilio del sospechoso rosa vamos
ahora con los medios anglófonos en japon
el japan times el yo para news
efectivamente y señalan también entre un
poco la actualización de los hechos pues
también como decíamos las reacciones
internacionales una que ha llamado mucho
la atención la del ex presidente de eeuu
donald trump diciendo que era un
verdadero amigo suyo pero más importante
todavía de eeuu por otro lado también
líderes de la unión europea también a
blinken etcétera con los mismos rasgos
de devastación al shock y de que está
sus pensamientos con la familia del ex
primer ministro y precisamente el japan
news también señala como la prensa
internacional a lo que iremos ahora está
llenando sus titulares y sus portadas
con estos hechos y que el financial
times por ejemplo dice que se trata del
mayor acto de violencia política que
azota japón en los últimos 50 años
repasamos ahora los titulares
internacionales dedicamos a dedicados a
esta noticia que estamos hablando rosa
vamos con el tiempo new times la cnn al
yazira y el south china morning post' y
básicamente sólo para repasar a medios
de distintas regiones para mostrarles
los que lo que les estábamos comentando
no en el tiempo en colombia dice sin
sabe muere el ex primer ministro japonés
tras atentado el 'new york times' sin
suave el primer ministro de japón más
duradero en el cargo muere a los 67 años
y siempre éste muere tan problemático
del 'new york times' no bueno no
exactamente no algo que ha sucedido en
otras ocasiones en todo caso el 'new
york times' también señala antes de
renunciar en 2020 mejoró la situación
económica de su país el ave no mix que
comentábamos pero no acabo de lograr su
objetivo más apreciado normalizar el
ejército de japón tras décadas de
pacifismo posguerra pues segunda guerra
mundial y básicamente señalar que una de
las cosas que ha impactado mucho
precisamente de que esto tenga de que
este crimen haya sido perpetrado con una
arma de fuego es que japón tal y como
señalan distintos en medios de
comunicación un país de 127 millones de
habitantes apenas registra unas 10
muertes por armas de fuego al año
mientras que en eeuu el último año del
que se tiene constancia 2020 se
registraron 40 más de 45 mil muertes por
armas de fuego de las cuales la mitad
fueron suicidios pero la otra mitad
homicidios rosa y bueno dejamos a un
lado esta noticia de su suave para
cerrar con las portadas del mundo al
primer ministro de icaza primer ministro
británico versión son que renunció ayer
sino que deberíamos dejar de cerrar esta
semana con la noticia que sin duda la ha
marcado desde que el lunes empezarán
estas renuncias dentro de su gobierno
básicamente como bien comentábamos ayer
que las en papel todavía no anunciaban
la renuncia de boris johnson porque se
vio ya cuando estaban los periódicos en
circulación hoy sí que ya tenemos esta
despedida a lo largo y ancho del planeta
vemos aquí algunas de las portadas
europeas no precisamente de liberación
siempre con estas portadas tan a
gráficas boris johnson bigben no pero
con este juego de palabras 20 golpes en
francés pero si te parece pasemos al
otro gráfico que teníamos también han
preparado porque mi portada favorita mi
titular favorita es el del medio del
hindú de de la india que dice boris
johnson renuncia como primer ministro
finaliza un drama político en reino
unido- me parece que esto sintetiza muy
bien toda la saga que ha sido estos
últimos meses no de boris johnson al
frente del ejecutivo británico así es
rosa como siempre muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda esta revista de prensa
feliz fin de semana nos vemos el lunes
por supuesto con más pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día